So, here's one way to answer this question. We have
our two variable definitions. We can print out the distance
light travels in one cycle by dividing speed of light
by cycles per second using the variables, and when we
run that we see the result is 0.11. So, that's
0.11 meters, or 11 centimeters. Another way to solve this
that might be better would be to introduce another variable.
So, instead of just printing the result, we can store
it in a variable. We'll call it cycle_distance. Now, when
we run it, there's no result. We haven't printed that
out yet. But we've stored it in a variable. And
now, we can print out the result of cycle_distance. Which gives
us the 11, 0.11 meters. If we want the result
in centimeters, well since we've already stored the result in meters
in a variable, we can compute that by just multiplying
that by 100. And now we get the result in centimeters.